[Musica]
chi cazzo è questa bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj e oggi
siamo su troll tail che sarebbe un video
che in tipo troll face quest solo che
non è non è troppo facebook m dale del
bel nome tra ecco perché c'è una vecchia
con una maschera da lupo che ha
catturato un lupo con una maschera da
vecchia ok non è una cosa normale già
questa è la capire che cosa si fumano i
creatori di sto gioco però non è roba
buona e questo sicura che se già partiti
ovviamente ragazzi con certe tifo quello
di troll face questa niente uguale solo
che cambia la storia
io sono questo bellissimo andiamo avanti
perfettamente è un gioco noi non scendo
così le colline ragazzi e tutto normale
tranquille diamo per gli eventi andare
avanti finché non che fa a cazzotti
ok l'utilità di questa minchiata sto
cambiando ieri da ma qualcuno pensava
che questo gioco avesse un senso non
perché si sbagliava di grosso cioè per
carità mica mi fa piacere che ci siano
giochi che l'api bird class asado fare
io mi devo più bello devo devo schivare
i cosi fantastico ecco non è così brava
fatti bar di mini one a ok dovevo
sbattere contro il tuo perfetto processo
sarà una bellissima questa clicco cioè
una randa calamità ragazzi da sola ok ho
una rana e non ho paura di usarla ce li
devo fare salve 20 britney spears si
appresta a porta perché non è noi che
possono darci io c'è una ragnatela
lancio addosso a senti devo cliccare si
è spostata la nuova che cazzo fai
[Musica]
qualcuno mi spiega da dove è partita la
musica e soprattutto che cazzo fa su un
tronco vabbè sentite io c'ho questa la
sola l'ho tirato una run it giustamente
era proprio questa l'idea ho trovato
mappa che viene tutto quando ragazzi è
tutta una calamita into gioco piccole
cose mie mi arrivano in mano da sole già
fantastico domanda cosa è fascista cazzo
ne faccio di una bacchetta
ma chi è che non ha mai sognato di
trasformare un mostro in una pila di
merda a caso mi fa veramente piacere che
giunto game negli anni facciano
progressi fantastica devo scegliere
oscar taglio dei pacchi dalla mi avete
inviato un cazzo rado con l'ultimo
regalo qua ho trovato perfetto è una
trappola per orsi ma perché è una
trappola per oggi io non voglio far
domande scott hodes io devo cliccare su
questo gli sta vicino
ma no ma pomeriggio sono cagati addosso
perfetto dove sono cliccare qui c'è io
devo andare
l'obiettivo di sua c'è un campanello ho
suonato
nonostante questo è più divertente
bellistri acqua dokic aran a ok oggi ok
il suo livello è l'unico più difficile
finora perché fa file e file
equilibrista perché non lo sai fare
l'equilibrista quindi evitiamo la
prossima volta
buongiorno ovviamente scoreggia se lo
cli chi non si sa perché non ho capito
ma non importa
ecco perfetto duplicare mai stesso io
sto zitto
ok cioè non senso però va bene così
quel povero cristo non aveva fatto
niente dormiva magari se gli chiedevi la
chiave era merce nel tela dava anche
cosa cazzo serve la chiave sentire i
calci alle porte a bella energia come
stanno gli cosa ci fai sulle scale poi
ciao piace favi james ma vengo in pace
in pace un paio di casi prove vengo non
ho capito perché mi saluta fu sorpreso
sono fatto una barba colpi e va bene
adesso mi mi accoglie nato a umile
dimorano perfetto devo farmi impedimento
è una maschera come mimì serve un naso
più più bello sono così
anche il caffè è giustamente il cappello
ma ha mai capita spesso di rubare
cappelli a gli spaventapasseri che poi
vengono inseguiti da gnomi vabbè la
bocca ascolta zia non è che ti vanno un
po di patate perché io non so se delle
patate possano essere gradite da questa
cortese donzella però non io sono alto
un metro e un bene però sono romantico
mini devia marmi o spaventato un nano
questo è il mio potere quindi amami
subito a duplice che cazzate che duri il
7 a caso i ragazzi sono i gatti 7
fantast fantastico è stata comunque una
storia d'amore migliore di twilight è
sembra un bel giorno quello dove ti
attaccano lane amico ecco come non detto
ancora la merda il mio amico questo è il
mio amico di prima miss are c'è solo
salto non dirmi che pestano non lo hanno
schivato navigando perché la merda
realtà quanto lo è che cosa è successo
ma che carine con coraggio che è stata
il filo ve lo sentiva affanculo
gli ho tirato un calcio davvero
inspiegate l'utilità di questi livelli
dove cade ma ancora sinani ma basta che
stanno seguendo da anni spina scotto zia
ci sono dei nani che mi metteresti in
pentola non posso tipo così a signora be
fai fai la pasta a giudicare dalla
pentola ne fanno e poi quanto a mia
nonna di pasta quindi so più o meno lei
le porzioni state emesse sei contenta
che cucino io che non ti devi alzare
dalla sedia con i sei saltando di gioia
non ho capito perché c'è una trave
girone entrare i nani giusto aggiungere
ma al prefetto ma ho visto la freccia o
saperlo ci avrei scommesso cazzo non
entrato per cassano ancora in seguito
pronto pizza ordinato due allora era mia
nonna che che che ha visto che ha
mangiato la clava sarà un'altra thesis e
incazzata la devo fagà devo cliccare
sulla norma gli ho lanciato il telefono
mia nonna perfetto no potuti tali
livelli caso c'è ancora un anno che mi
segue tra l'altro che non capire quale
andrebbe di fare tipo titanic
non so se un caso ma mi fa cliccare
proprio sulle tette c'è da altre parti
nole chicco sulle le partono dei capelli
dalle dette giusto le dispiace grazie
mille molto gentile turno sbircia
non tardare che qual è la mia donna ti
spacco di botte ancora non ho capito
dove stiamo andando però ascoltarlo a
furia di far uova si è diventata
isterica non lo so non l'ho capito
stai tranquilla rosita mia che mo
torniamo al mulino gennaro che cosa ci
fanno che cosa ci fa ancorata ancora la
talpa talpe col mal di testa
prossimamente al cinema che sono fare
con la tappa e non capirà se puntate con
un magnete a capo posto grazie a me lo
tengo anzi te lo dà in testa proprio
dimesso un magnete inter ma sì tutto
quello che vanno insegnato in fisica
fino adesso è una cazzata mondiale tutto
più date ragazzi non so se vi potete
divertire ma io c'ho questo giocattolo
belli perfetto avrei scommesso mi
sarebbe piaciuto di qualsiasi tipo entrò
a caso d'antoni giocate tranquilli a
twister che è successo io se fossi in te
la sceglierei un pochino meno rumoroso
c'è guarda se c'è un modello più
aggiornate voti per svegliarla o cose
così è una patacca eccola la patata è
tornata utile alla fine guarda che la
patata buona è questa qui è non inutile
che avete delle mogli che fanno casino
ci penso io che sono affacciato a terra
tra l'altro bellissimo devo tirare la
leva è però non va più di così
fantastico bello delle mie soluzioni
ecco che qualcuno desidera frittelle
crepe
no perché sono molto brava a fare adesso
posso passare volendo haifa haifa giusto
ok colta voi un fazzoletto fai fai da te
vorrei coccolarti però però sei morto so
niente si sta incalzando ma che hanno la
macchina io sono più o meno così quando
mi svegliai più o meno a mi ascolta io
vado prima che questo vi impazzisca di
bruciare non ho capito dove stiamo
arrivando
grandi ragazzi ma arrivati a casa di mia
nonna mi sarò suonare i campanelli
[Musica]
a noi oggi io tiro calci alle cose
giustamente purtroppo trovato una leva a
caso ok dopo c grazie ivan dia primi la
porta per favore ecco no perché lì ci
fantastico è stata certo ma ceca adesso
sicuro che può iniziare con tasti l'ho
fatta sono arrivato a chiasso
smascherato il lupo ok adesso ti sei
bravissima non ha brava sei fantastica
[Musica]
qualcuno ha capito qualcosa io non ho
capito un cazzo di quello che jen
completo 28 minuti e 9 secondi di gioia
soprattutto con mia nonna ragazzi è
stato silvio la trama perché è stata
molto chiara quindi alla venite io mi
sono svegliato la mattina
mia nonna mi ha chiamato al telefono mi
ha chiesto vieni a mangiare la pasta nel
frattempo che ci andavo mangiato da
un'altra tizia dei nani poi il lupo
cattivo non so che il cazzo c'entra va
però era un figlio quindi ci hanno messo
dentro a caso se anche voi non avete
capito un cazzo di quello che abbiamo
appena giocato la scelta un commento mi
piacciono veramente a parte gli scherzi
locali si cosi mi rende più
rincoglionito di quanto non sia io
normalmente però va bene lo stesso vi
ringrazio per amico sigliato questo
capolavoro videoludico moderno mini
grazie a tutti i ragazzi salvi dove
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come la
divido tra ten descrizione senza doversi
fischiate noi ci vediamo a un prossimo
video spero che sia che si capisca e
vabbè bella ragazzi